and right now the first of many
graduation ceremonies for seniors in the
clark county school district advanced
technologies academy graduation underway
over at thomas and mack that is where we
find sasha loftis
joining us live with those proud
graduates
brian those graduates just turned their
tassels here the ceremony is just
wrapping up it was a pretty special day
as the advanced technologies academy or
academy
graduation here one of many that's back
in person after months of distance
learning
and students say it's just really a
magical day for them
now about 250 students don their caps
and gowns today
many speaking on the difficulties this
year brought them
as these students haven't been together
in person since march of last year but
those difficulties make this day even
more special we spoke with the school's
principal earlier he shared how much
these kids have really gone through and
how great it is to see them together
again
this has been an incredibly challenging
year especially for our seniors because
they in march 2020 that was their last
day in school
so they missed out on that whole end of
last year and then
they haven't seen a lot of their friends
in person since actually friday when we
had our
senior cap and gown distribution and it
was incredible to see them
get together and really connect as a
class one
more time now the school's principal
also said this was the first event that
was held
at the thomas and max since march of
last year this is
also the first time this particular
school is holding this ceremony here at
this location
they said it's just another way to
really show those grads how important
they are
and how special this day is after such a
difficult year
of that distance learning reporting live
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now